how can we expose them even further well
one way is to mock them and show their
nonsensical racist
diatribes for themselves uh and now we
got the we got the warning yeah there we
go sorry uh yeah we got something from
The View here's Sonny Austin and for
Anna
um one of my issues has always been I
don't understand how a Latina woman
right who even left them from Nicaragua
could be part of a of a party that's
when I became when I came to this
country when I came to this country the
Republican party was the party that
stood up against communism and that is
something that is ingrained in me in the
same way that being a Catholic isn't
greater than you but listen when Pope
Benedict who was part of parcel of
covering up the pedophilia scandal in
the church was Pope you still stayed in
the Catholic church as you know because
there's more to it I actually stopped
going to church but wait that is not
listen all of this has nothing to do
with the question
don't even ask what the question was it
doesn't even matter honestly but do you
see what they do Sonny Hassan who is he
she is a racist and an idiot I mean she
is truly the worst person on on network
television there's so many of them but
Sunny really is number one and she's
like racing away with it you know what I
mean there used to be horse races like
is it stelter is it Don Lemon is it you
know but Sunny is just bam she's lapping
these people in the most bigoted [ __ ]
on on television
um to turn to a Latina woman and say you
are not in command of your mind you you
must vote the way that I want you to
vote in and of itself is racist if you
think that all black people must vote a
certain way or all gay people must vote
a certain way and they must think the
way you think they must think you are
the racist you are the bigot that is the
summation of what the left has at the
moment and it's also interesting because
uh Anna Navarro she I don't know that
she considers herself a republican
anymore I mean basically she's a
progressive right so it's all lefties on
that show and then they've got Alison
farra this fake conservative something
right but she her main gig what got her
popular and what put her on The View was
that she worked for Marco Rubio Marco
Rubio whose parents came from Cuba and
Marco's been on the show and he's
described the the scene growing up of
his parents working in kitchens praying
that they could get a little bit of a
better life from what they fled and now
their son is a freaking Senator and
former presidential candidate they know
what they fled and it's interesting she
also says well I'm a republican because
Republicans were against communism
Democrats basically are communists at
this point I I think you could argue I
don't wanna I don't want to make a big
deal about it but I think you could
argue the Democrats are basically
fascist at this point I don't want to
play their game but they love the
combination of Corporation and political
power oh you get jabbed because the
government told the corporation to do it
right that's anti-individual all right I
won't play their games to the extent
that they play them but watching them
eat themselves alive is just spectacular